Like i hope i do and i saw them
alive in on her and were in charge.
Working too
and you know i'm interested
to hear you know.
Who. And she's so good.
Well i came to this area
about 14 years ago.
My name's katrina shields
and i came to this area 14 years ago
originally to live on a community called body
farm that had about 20
adults and 15 children.
That time and i had been living
on another community in victoria.
That i joined after coming back
from india had lived in the east
and particularly india and
nepal for a couple of years
and i knew i didn't want
to go back to being.
An occupational therapist and.
Working as a professional
in the mainstream.
So i guess i chose to drop right out
but i was very much attracted to
what was happening in this area
and on hearing about
body farm i came up here
and originally to do a month long
meditation retreat and i stayed
and joined body farm and lived
there for four and a half years
and still part of that community and but
have since moved to the village nearby
and come and gone over
that time. Work to do so.
Richly i was drawn to
the ethical structure.
At the i was strongly in for influenced
and interested in buddhist meditation
practice and had been involved in
that very strongly in india and knew i
wanted to live a rural community life
but the community.
I was on had a very loose structure
and wasn't really working for me and
when i met these people i guess i was really
struck by their spirit you know there
was just something.
That they had going as a group particularly
the men the way they were together they
were really soft and open and
sharing that was the initial thing
that attracted me and then they told me
about the structure of the community
and the fact that the five buddhist
precepts were the basis of the community
and that just instantly struck a chord
with me and i wanted to go and find out.
And as soon as i walked in i just had this
really strong feeling this is my place.
You know i'm and it and
i just fell into place.
It is and i was very happy being there
and i still feel very strongly
connected to that group
and feel like they're my kin.
Although i have a large
extended family in melbourne.
These people and if the
word kin seems to cover.
How i feel you know we don't
always like each other but
but there's a strong commitment to each
other and we know heaps about each other
and. Yeah we're just we're you
know sort of sticking together.
Yeah.
Yeah was very much motivated
initially by bein in a search.
Again.
Initially i was motivated by an
inner sort of spiritual inquiry.
And personal growth that's what nisha lee
drew me of wanting to discover more about
myself.
How to grow as a person how to overcome
my own hang ups how to extend myself
and so i was very attracted to
all sorts of personal growth.
Stuff and also learning how to
build and grow organic vegetables
and make mud bricks
and you know live very simply
because i've been i lived in india
and saw how they lived there and
it really touched me very deeply
that i just couldn't go on consuming
and having as much as i saw around me
i see that we couldn't sustain that.
So i was very attracted to
living very simply and then
that sort of grew from there
that i after a number of years.
I felt drawn back into the mainstream
that i wanted to to make bridges
back in to a wider society
that somehow wasn't i wasn't personally
being nourished enough by the isolation of
the community but also i
wanted to be stretched.
I actually stepped out by setting out
setting up a small business in lismore a
health food business.
But then i was also offered locums
back doing occupational therapy
and health promotion which is what
i'd done before. So it drew me back.
So i wanted to spend the two worlds
and say ok we did experiment with weather
alternatives wouldn't learnt a lot in the
process. How can we use
that to sort of nourish what was
happening in the mainstream you know
and bring really good things about the
mainstream back into alternative society.
You know hell with things about
time management and being efficient
and getting things done and
really making things happen
that i want to also bring back
into alternative society.
You know that
that it wasn't all about you know just
lazing around having a good time.
Although actually we worked really
hard. It's not true that we set.
Around under trees contemplating our
navels i think i think i probably worked
harder in those days you
know 16 hour days hell.
It was making mud bricks
or working in the garden.
So sometimes were actually workaholic
about what we did but we had a good time.
With those you know. Quite strict.
Yeah
and i was probably amongst the strict you know
i was really on about being ideologically
sound and you know everybody
should work really hard and
and you couldn't have anything
but organic vegetables
and you know alcohol was very taboo
and cigarettes were outrageous
and you know cars were morally unsound
either if i was pretty strict
and i guess a lot of us were we were very
idealistic you know we really wanted to
be sound about what we were doing and
we didn't want to be on the dole so
that meant living on the
smell of an oil he wreck
and getting by very little because we
didn't have many sources of income.
So yeah i think we're pretty
hard line of softened up a lot.
You know i don't think it
was bad to be like that
but i don't know if it was so sustainable.
So what the hell those that work.
I i moved back into the mainstream
and now working part time as a councillor
in a women's health centre focusing
particularly on older women.
But i also do training and development
work with community groups run workshops
and trainings
and conflict resolution working
together anti burnout strategies
and team building things like that.
In the book a manual about. First much.
Yeah yeah well the book grew out of this.
I ended up writing a book which
was a synthesis of the ideas
and the experiments wed had
and learning from each other
and living in community in being involved
in social change campaigns fighting for
the rainforests working
on peace issues and also.
Synthesizing the personal growth
to the counseling the creativity.
And. Learning how to be effective
in social change work.
And bringing a more heart politics
approach into what we did.
So this this turned into a menu
of all those different aspects.
With exercises that i and
others had used to grow
and to work together in groups.
And so of help is i mean.
Well the term politics was originally
coined by a woman called brand peavey who
happened to be american.
And yes it means bringing together that
which is normally seen as a separate
but the heart. They are most
vulnerable part our loving caring.
And innermost being bringing
that together with.
Influencing social change. Having power.
The structures that bring about.
Movement in society and we often see
hat as being incredibly separate from
that that. A lot of the
models of power and of.
Social change seen as you know
corrupt just out these so.
Wielding power not caring
about the consequences
that any means justify the ends and all
of us felt pretty disgusted by that.
And very unattracted to that
way of bringing about change.
So we've been experimenting with a whole
lot of different ways to bring the two
together. What what does a personal growth
and spiritual movement have to do
with gnashing political action
and sustaining political action and
drawing people in who feel powerless
and uninvolved.
We originally got attracted to this.
During the early 80s
when many of us felt incredible
despair about the nuclear issue
that we had heaps of information about what
was likely to happen what could happen
what was happening and it
was pretty hard to respond.
The threat was so huge and you
know i felt sick and overwhelmed
and depressed
and we came across some methods for
transforming those feelings into effective
action and that was to actually grieve
to validate our despair and to recognise
that our responses were really a sane
reaction to an insane situation and
that perhaps no other generation had had
to face up squarely to the fact of its own
extinction
that many of us grew up feeling like there
just wasn't a future whether it was an
alternative future or whether it was the
one mapped out to it. By the mainstream.
So that's a pretty hard thing to give up
the feeling like what's the use of having
children. Were you know
if we do have children.
What are we bringing them into so we
were facing pretty strong despair
and so we experimented with
methods for working with grief.
Ritual work.
Support groups to bring that
out and what we found was
that by going quite deeply into
that despair that and hopelessness
that we felt it actually liberated
a lot of energy and hope
that was the amazing thing.
That the more we acknowledge
that fully the more passion
for life came through and
that actually we were connecting deeper
sources of energy and realizing that
that pain came from.
A a feeling and a knowing of our
interconnectedness we hurt because we cared.
We hurt because we were part of
life and life was threatened.
We weren't personally
necessarily threatened
but we could see what was happening to
other species and what might happen.
And so it was by validating that
interconnection that the more power
and sense of being able
to affect change grew.
But then we also needed to learn skills you
know how do you organize how do you run
groups how do you conduct
meetings how do you get rallies
that really get people along.
How can we have fun doing this.
We are only doing it for the rest of our
life you know so we really want to enjoy
it and so a lot of what we'd
learnt in living in community
and working on social campaigns you know
brought back together with this emotional
and spiritual work.
Yeah yeah that.
I think so we're trying to make
something positive out of something
that was very negative like
a threat to the future.
The possible loss completely of our
future or at least all this beauty
and this environment that
we could see around us.
The extinction of species pollution
of the air and water have a turn
that into a source for also celebration
and.
Drawing on inner resources in
ourselves and each other and see
that yet as a cause for celebration.
That you know there's much to do and
that can be done joyfully. And how.
Fully effectively because it's not
just about having a good time.
We also want to make effective change
and that's that's an ongoing challenge
to me but a lot of these people
that are very left brain and
like we've got no time for fun
and you know we've got no time to sit down
and work on our relationships because the
campaign you know there's this campaign
and there's this meeting and
hell is this deadline like that.
That's no more effective.
You know so really facing up to the
fact that if you burn people out
and you have such a lousy time.
It doesn't work you know it's you're
not building a social change movement.
So it seemed
that building movements for change really
needed something much more integrated
that meant we knew how to live together
we knew how to resolve conflicts.
When you had to support each other we
knew had or were effectively do meetings.
You know stick to agendas plan campaigns
and a lot of the lessons of
community came out of that
that if you can live together
and bring two children together
and solve your conflicts.
You've got great resources
for then going out
and changing what's happening in your town
or changing what's happening
much wider than your town.
The heart of.
Well perhaps the heart politics
is whether it was. Feminine.
I actually see it as an
integration of the masculine
and the feminine principle if you like
if you see traditionally the feminine
principle as been about you know caring
and heart and nurturing and nurturing
and the masculine principle about being
you know organized and effective
and upfront and leadership
and exercising power.
I see that happen. Bringing
those two together their boss.
Necessary all heart you
know might feel good
but it's not going to bring about change.
Necessarily and all all
head isn't going to last
and people want to be part of it.
So i see how politics is bringing the
head and the heart you know the spirit
and the body.
The masculine and feminine together
to turn our she each other
and hopefully have the best
of both. Yeah you know.
The. Way you. Change.
You know.
Oh very extreme ways.
So what some of the extremes
we went to in the early days.
Well there was the extreme hard line
and i know i was one of those really
trying to stick very rigidly to ideology
and eschew anything from the mainstream
that might be you know
tainting our alternatives.
But i guess we're pretty extreme about you
know things like experimenting with bio
energetic there p.
You know big cathartic releases
and and you know nudity
and. Things like that and you
know i look back and chuckle.
Now at some of those things
some of the naivete.
Perhaps that we approached things
and i was thinking about you
know i set up a small business
and in selling health foods and i
think credibly naive about business.
I went in thinking i was just doing
it because it was doing good.
It never occurred to me that would make
money or that it should make money.
You know i just didn't think like it
was just what's good for the group.
Now i think i'd stop and say well it was
going to make it because that matters. So.
I don't know what other extremes
perhaps extremes of sort of poverty.
That we're subjected ourselves to mean i
lived for quite a long time in a tent in
the rainforest and then graduated
onto sheds without wall.
Amongst the leeches and the ticks
and the snakes and the frogs
and i mean they have it's real
beauty but it wasn't that practice.
And your clothes went mouldy and you
know you got sick and got pretty cold
and damp and wet and i don't
think you could keep that up.
And you know washing your clothes in the
creek with cold water and you know.
I didn't have any electricity because
that was very bush where.
So yeah it was really good to experience
that but it wasn't sustainable.
You know i guess i got sick of that and.
I discovered when i wanted to move back
into the mainstream and hold down a job.
Even if it was a part time job.
Well i had to turn up
looking kind of reasonable.
Wasn't any good if my clothes
were covered in mold
and you know hadn't been washed
and even though i might have
really good reasons for
that it just wasn't going
to go down very well.
Yeah or. It wasn't deliberate.
Yeah it wasn't deliberate to say you know
look how poor we are or whatever but.
But yeah i first were trying to
stretch the limits of how austere
and how self-sufficient i felt really
strongly about being self-sufficient
that it mattered that i grew
my own food and if that meant
that i was only living on you know
the vegetables out of the garden
and that's what i do and i and i
used to feel offended if people went
and bought imported tofu or something
like that. You know if ended some.
I'm really strongly held principle and
you know you could make your own clothes
and could recycle and you know you
could cut down use of the car
and we didn't need electricity and
hot water was a bit of a luxury
and yet i think i took
it a bit farther than.
All those. Right.
Well the book's called in the
tiger's mouth and that grew out of
that for some time we were joined on the
community by a buddhist monk who was a
political refugee from thailand his life
was threatened by his political activities
and so he lived on the farm and
wrote poetry and paintings
and contemplated and he gave a painting
to each person on the community
and i came home one day and
on the floor of my hut.
He had done this painting in very
simple brushstrokes of a rampant tiger
and the caption was the best place for
meditation is in the tiger's mouth
and i couldn't make a lot of sense of
it at the time but i realized later
that then i was very much into withdrawal
that i wanted to practice meditation
and be away from the
hurly burly to be quiet
and to be with my my clan
with my chosen family
and perhaps not have to mix it with that
rather yucky world out there and later
when we came involved in
campaigns to save the rainforest
and in other social issues. I
realized what he was getting at.
He was saying hey maybe meditation
really has its fruition
when you can keep an open mind and
open heart and the spirit of inquiry
when you're in the thick of it.
You know and get back out there.
So that's been my challenge and i think
that he was what i was trying to tell me.
How. Yes. Yep here.
Initially i think my focus
was on my personal growth
and our groups personal growth
and creating alternatives
and now i see the movement back into the
mainstream to take what we've learned
and experimented with back in
and take what's good about the
mainstream back into the alternative
that they're not so separate now.
I mean things we were talking about
that were considered extremely
radical i mean organic agriculture.
Or or even you know sharing
in community or things like
that are now just very run of the military
everybody can talk about it which is
great. Challenges.
Our heads. Well the world
still in a pretty bad state.
And there's just a mean it's a worse
state than it was 14 years ago.
Maybe you nuclear cloud has lifted somewhat
although we have still have an enormous
threat from nuclear waste.
That it hasn't gone away.
So there's lots of challenges about how
we're really going to affect change
and to do that.
We're going to have to work together in
ways which we've only had glimpses of.
And i think one of the pros the
legacies of the post aquarius was
you know how can we can
come together and live
and learn from each other in
a in a very open way that
that lesson still needs to go on.
You know we need to know how how can
we actually sustain life on earth
and cooperate and understand each other.
It's i mean it's happening all over the
world not just the syria of course.
But we need it more than ever.
Then.
Right.
Initially my spiritual search was focused
very much on meditation practice.
I saw that as being the main vehicle
for growth and change and must.
My sitting practice to getting contact
with deeper energies within myself
and to understand my mind
and. It's hard to talk.
And living as a strong ethical structure
of the buddhist precepts was important.
Now i see that is still important. I
don't meditate as much as i used to.
I still like to have a
retreat. Once a year.
But we can be in silence and get back
in contact with myself but i try
and bring my spiritual practice into
everything i do you know whether it's doing
the counselling work i do with women
or working on a campaign to clean
up you know the local area
or working on a committee in the local
government to introduce more community
consultation. I see
that as the arena for spiritual practice
how can i listen to this person
that i have incredibly
different views with.
And still stay open hearted and how
can i find a way to cooperate.
You know how can i work on my own stuff
so that we're not so much in conflict.
Heck and i maintain my balance
and how can i keep trusting
you know just trusting that
that there's good in other people
that there's good around me and
that i can draw on energy that's
much bigger and wider than me.
I mean this times when i'm running
workshops and maybe emphasis.
Let having a conflict
that happened last week a large
group 33 people lots of conflict
and they've brought me into
try and you know fix it up
and i'm standing there thinking hell i
can't do this you know this is too hard.
I'd rather be anywhere but
here this just feel terrible.
But maybe it's just that moment
of thinking well i'm not just me.
You know maybe i can open
myself to wider energies.
You know can i be a channel here for having
these people appreciate each other you
know to get back to basics and find some
some caring and. Willing to listen.
And so maybe it's just a moment
of reflection and grounding and.
Prayer really and and when i do that.
Amazing things happen you know and i
know that's not just coming from me so.
I guess that's how some of the ways in which
i experience my spiritual practice now
here you know.
I remain optimistic by seeing
results you actually see
that the stuff works that
people can cooperate that.
I've experienced growth in myself.
I've experienced in almost
growth in the people around me.
I've seen groups turn around
from a point of conflict
and hopelessness to
optimism and cooperation.
I've seen campaigns that
work. I've seen how so.
The change in consciousness about
rainforests you know in in 10 years.
It's really turned around so i
remain optimistic by seeing the
results and by having a good time to go
that. I enjoy what i do and that.
It feeds me and. I work with a lot
of loving people and that feeds me.
Yeah you do so.
Yeah i think they are i think
they're very they're query
and ideals i see as being very relevant.
I mean they're not know about long
hair and beards and you know barefoot
and pregnant. I mean that
they were very much externals
but i see the values of cooperation of
living closely to the earth to be open
to nature voluntary simplicity
experimentation personal growth.
I see them as incredibly relevant more
relevant now than they were then you know
that. Perhaps
that was naive idealism
and perhaps it would.
Have lost the word its.
Self-absorption but they were good ideals
and i see the nineties as being you know
the place where they're needed more than
ever. You know they the
excesses of the 80s
and the greed of the 80s
has really taught us
that we need it more than ever.
When you hear.
I say women's issue as being a strong thread
that's been running through the growth
and change. I mean for me as a
woman but also in the movements.
I remember we made a video of the struggle
for to rainier creek rainforest about
13 years ago and in playing it again.
I mean people say yeah
but where are the women you know the
guys we're getting up and talking.
They were really taking the lead. We
were certainly there we were doing.
In a lot of work but we weren't speaking
up and we didn't see that as our place.
You know.
So in fact there was a hell of a lot of an
ism really running through a lot of the
alternative communities
the women were barefoot
and pregnant washing the nappies
wala guys were our building
and in fact sex roles were very strong
and they they were very strong in
a lot of social change groups.
So it's been really important for women
to get together and to empower ourselves
and to draw on the wider women's movement
to nourish action within the alternative
community and in our piece groups
and in our community action groups to say
hey we've got we've got an equal voice
we've got skills. We need to be empowered.
We need to empower each other
and work together is a calls
and so that's been that's been
an important lesson i think
that came quite late to the
alternative movement or things
that were acceptable still on communities
around here wouldn't have been acceptable
and in many of the city
groups. That you know.
Who are you know. The
differences were higher.
So yes yes i think the the
sheer physical reality
that many of us were living in unfortunately
initially highlighted some of the sex
roles. Look there's a baby on the way
and there's a house to be built.
You know is this a time for the woman
tell you know start at square one.
Learning how to build
or she's got a baby on a hip i mean who you
know is it going to be quicker for her
to wash the nappies and feed the
baby and him to get on with building
and unfortunately.
You know officially ruled often
and and it's and it got more
and more engrained in that
way but many of us said hey.